imagine tu es en pleine attaque au foot
tu te prends un tacle et fractures
ouvertes ça saigne beaucoup il te faut
absolument une transfusion
malheureusement tu n'avais qu'une chance
sur deux puissances 69 que ça tombe sur
toi mais tu l'art le groupe sanguin le
plus rares au monde
à l'hôpital ils ne pourront rien pour
toi comment va-t-on faire pour te sauver
la science a peut être la solution
dans cette vidéo on va explorer tous les
secrets et mystères qui regorge dans le
sang humain connais-tu tomberait groupe
sanguin toi devant ton écran je peux
deviner ton groupes sanguins situés
norvégien tu dois être du groupe à et
revient au cd facile au pérou 71% de la
population et aux en norvège 49% et a
comme tu le sais le groupe sanguin et
terry d'iter ce sont tes parents qui te
donnent des versions du gène qui code
tout ton groupe ça marche exactement
comme la couleur de tes yeux ou de tes
cheveux regarde ce tableau a et b sont
forts alors que au est faible c'est à
dire que pour être au il faut que les
deux parents te donne la version os du
gène alors que pour être adoubé il
suffit que un parent ne le donne mais
contrairement à l'idée reçue c'est pas
parce que cauet faible qu'il va
disparaître de la population eau sera
caché en toi et aura toujours une chance
d'être transmis c'est comme pour les
roues sachez que son que vous soyez à b
ou au vous aurez quelques
caractéristiques spéciales vas-y on
pense que ça influencerait ton caractère
cloud de ff7 serait à bécaud notant un
caractère secret est imprévisible ça
colle non bah ça c'est du sacré bout de
shit une étude de 2003 a montré que ça
ne changeait absolument rien par contre
avant le groupe sanguin du type auto
rendra plus sexy aux yeux des moustiques
si tu es le seul à te faire dévorer en
pique nique tu sais maintenant pourquoi
lui faut encore on a pu faire des liens
entre le risque d'avoir certaines
maladies comme un ulcère un cancer de la
peau ou une maladie cardiaque en
fonction de ton groupe sanguin ces
découvertes sont récentes et on ne sait
pas encore ce qui provoque ces
inégalités face à la maladie depuis tout
à l'heure on parle de à bab haut mais en
réalité il y à beaucoup plus de groupes
sanguins que tu ne le penses déjà il ya
ton rhésus le plus ou le moins après la
lettre ça tu le connais par contre connu
tu ton qu'elle août ont deux filles ce
sont les autres systèmes de
classification de ton groupe sanguin et
il ya encore plus d'une quarantaine de
différentes pour chacun de ces systèmes
plusieurs combinaison existe on parle du
groupe sanguin est tendue imagine tu la
quantité astronomique de groupes
sanguins différents que cela peut faire
plusieurs millions en fait tu vois sur
cette image le groupe à bo est là dont
les us est ici et tout le reste c'est
d'autres groupes et encore il en manque
alors julia la rédactrice de cette vidéo
par exemple et au résulte plus grande et
plus grand c'est plus grande - petit c -
petit plus qui elle - et les animaux aux
mêmes leur propre groupe sanguin ton
chien aider à un point négatif cool
c'est un donneur universel pour les
chiens bref tu l'auras compris il ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
groupes sanguins différents les
mécanismes de l'évolution qui ont
conduit à cette quantité astronomique
sont multiples et encore méconnu ça
pourrait être les maladies mais aussi le
climat voire même l'altitude mais ça
change quoi pour toi en train de te
guider de ton sang à l'hôpital pour
contrainte ça il faut qu'on parle d'une
donnée méga importante il se passe quoi
si on injecte du sang incompatibles les
premières expérimentations de
transfusion date du xviie siècle cette
époque on tente de sauver un jeune
garçon qui a subi plus d'une vingtaine
de saigner pour traiter sa fièvre en lui
transfuser du sang d'agneau d'après
l'histoire il aurait survécu une autre
aventure plus documenté et celle
d'antoine maury en 1668 mari violent
prix d'accès de folie furieuse à cause
d'une syphilis qui lui a grignoté le
cerveau son médecin lui transfuser du
sang de veau pour essayer de le calmer
car oui à l'époque on pensait que le
comportement d'une personne était régi
par ses humeurs et les liquides qui
composent son corps et notamment le sang
le remède pour un homme violent une
transfusion du sang d'animal tout mignon
tout doux bien sûr logique il racle
l'homme survie quelques temps et en plus
se calme non pas pour les bonnes raisons
mais probablement très affaibli par
cette transfusion à la troisième
transfusion il décédera avec des
douleurs terribles haut rhin de la
fièvre et du sang dans les urines avec
tous ces détails on sait qu'aujourd'hui
s'agissait d'une réaction à une erreur
de compatibilité transfusionnelle ben
oui transfuser du sang d'animal à un
humain bon ben ça marche pas il faudra
attendre 1818 pour voir émerger une
solution viable grâce à un gynécologue
james brandon altéré de voir ses
patients mourir à la chaîne d'hémorragie
à la naissance d'un enfant devant la
mort imminente d'une jeune femme le
gynécologue propose à son mari de lui
donner son propre sang et ça marche la
maman est sauvé et les progrès de la
science sur la transfusion sont en route
les différents groupes sanguins seront
couvert au tout début des années 1900
par karl landsteiner etc lors des
guerres mondiales que des avancées
fulgurantes émergent comme d'habitude il
faut vraiment attendre de se taper
dessus pour avancer alors ça y est on
aurait enfin compris pourquoi les
transfusions ne marchait pas à tous les
coups mais ça veut dire que toi avec ton
sens si rare tu ne pourras pas être
sauvée parce que tu es défenses
immunitaires vont te tuer c'est elle qui
vont venir mettre le sbbl ce qui était
censé être protégé va en fait de
condamner des globules rouges sont
recouverts d'antigènes des protéines qui
dépasse 2 tc hull ce sont elles qui
signale de quel groupe sanguin tués et
ton corps est programmé pour reconnaître
les antigènes qui ne sont pas à toi il
possède déjà les anticorps contre les
groupes sanguins différent du tien le
problème est là si on ne transmet pas le
bon sens ton corps va déclencher la
grande machine en cas d'agression et eve
rappel des troupes de défense
annihilation de l'envahisseur des
anticorps vont aller se fixer sur les
nouveaux globules rouges qu'on essaye de
te donner ces nouveaux globules rouges
vont s'agglutiner les uns aux autres
liés par les anticorps ça va former des
caillots risquant de boucher la
circulation du sang regarde on les voit
même se former à l'oeil nu alors imagine
dans ton corps ensuite des globules
blancs vont venir attaquer ces globules
rouges inconnu et détruire alors que tu
en a cruellement besoin pour remplacer
tout le sens que tu as perdu et en plus
cette destruction massive va générer un
paquet de déchets cellulaire qui va
venir enrayer tes organes c'est
l'accident hémolytique et la mort ça
peut même arriver pendant la grossesse
ça a été mon cas le corps de ma mère a
littéralement voulu me tuer elle avait
un résultat négatif et moi j'étais
positif ces anticorps ont voulu se
défendre contre ce sens étranger le mien
ça peut conduire à des fausses couches
ou des malformations heureusement il
existe des traitements qui neutralise la
production d'anticorps mortel avant
chaque transfusion on va regarder
comment il le groupe de la victime et le
sens qu'on va lui donner réagissant
ensemble si ça concorde c'est bon la
victime est sauvé et on peut lui
transfusé le sens mais ça c'est pour les
chanceux qui ont un groupe sanguin pas
trop rares toi pas tu as ce qu'on
appelle un sens en or ou rh nul tu te
souviens que ton groupe sanguin est
déterminé par les antigènes qu'il y a à
la surface de terribles rouge leçon rh
nul edit en or car sur les soixante et
un antigène différent du système rh tu
n'en as pas un seul toulis ça un énorme
avantage il ne peut être rejetée tuer le
donneur univers l ultime c'est une super
nouvelle pour les autres par contre pour
toi c'est une catastrophe on ne peut te
sauver qu'avec une transfusion d'un
groupe sanguin exactement identique au
tien tu n'as aucune marge de manoeuvre
contrairement reste de la population
dans le monde environ 42% de la
population et aux 29 % et à 23% et b i 6
% et ab le sens nord c'est
0,00 0,00
6% en gros vous êtes à peine 50 dans le
monde donc si tu n'as pas fait de stocks
avant tu ne peut compter que sur la
solidarité des 49 autres personnes dans
le monde qui ont un groupe sanguin
comment te sauver alors existe-t-il un
sang universel
ce serait la solution à tous nos
problèmes hémorragie maladie du sang
opération lourde aujourd'hui ça n'existe
pas mais on a des pistes tout part d'un
cadavre démembré retrouver dans la
tamise en 1958 la police découvre un
membre flottant à la surface après
examen la victime est identifiée du
groupe b quelques jours plus tard un
autre morceau du corps est découvert le
légiste est formel ce morceau appartient
bien au malheureux qui s'est fait
démembré mais un point capital ne colle
pas nouveaux membres et du groupe o
c'est à n'y rien comprendre
et là la découverte qui va devenir le
pilier du sang universel dans la tamise
outre les poissons les déchets on
retrouve un paquet de bactéries et l'une
d'entre elles en particulière elisabeth
kindia méningaud sceptiques à dans une
cale produit va couper la liaison qui
maintient l'antigène à ob sur le globule
rouge et si l'antigène les plus présents
le globule rouge à aubes et se
transforme alors en haut depuis les
chercheurs tentent de mettre au point
une technique rentable pour en produire
en grande quantité des avancées énormes
ont eu lieu il ya deux ans le sens
universel n'est peut-être pas si loin
mais en attendant on doit toujours
compter sur la solidarité des donneurs
on ne s'est pas créé du sang depuis zéro
et c'est bien dommage parce que le sang
humain c'est compliqué déjà les stocks
ils n'ont jamais été aussi bas alors
qu'on en a cruellement besoin ensuite
les maladies ne faudrait pas que vous en
donniez une aux personnes qui vont
recevoir votre sang mais vous allez me
dire qu'il suffirait juste de faire des
tests et vous avez raison on teste
chaque poche de sang mais certaines
maladies peuvent se cacher alors c'est
pour ça que certaines personne sont
strictement interdites de don du sang
trop jeune trop vieux juste après un
tatouage ou un piercing après un rapport
à risque et si vous avez vécu plusieurs
mois en angleterre entre 1980 et 1996
tiens c'est étrange comme règle que
s'est il passé à cette époque
le scandale de la vache folle une
maladie se répand parmi les élevages de
vaches des îles britanniques les bêtes
deviennent agressives elles ont des
troubles de l'équilibré
elle semble complètement folle on se
rend compte alors que quatre personnes
sont atteintes de la maladie de la vache
folle à cause d'une transfusion de sang
contaminé ils étaient ce qu'on a fait
juste avant me demanderez-vous là le
problème c'est que cette maladie n'est
pas due à un virus ou une bactérie qu'on
connaît bien c'est un prion un agent
pathogène constitué d'une protéine on ne
sait pas bien comment ils fonctionnent
pas de test pour les détecter pas de
traitement une mortalité assurer la
maladie s'attrape pas en mangeant un
animal contaminé et comme les symptômes
mais plusieurs mois à se déclarer on ne
sait pas qui est malade ou pas alors
dans le doute toutes les personnes ayant
vécu en grande bretagne sur cette
période est d'office exclus du don du
sang comme si on pouvait se le permettre
vu le peu de donneurs qu'il y à déjà on
estime qu'il manque environ trente mille
poches de sang pour que toutes les
personnes qui en ont besoin puissent
être correctement soigné et c'est de
pire en pire ces dernières années donner
son sang prend une heure et avec ça vous
sauver trois personnes même si vous
n'avez pas le fameux sens en or au final
c'est peut-être ça le plus dangereux
avec le sens c'est de ne pas en avoir
[Musique]